yes it's a day of reflecting on how when
I was seven years old I
had to run from The Killers who were
neighbors who wanted to kill my family
because we were just called Tootsie and
um during the hundred days I leave like
a wild animal living in Mass Graves and
watching people of my extended family
including my dad being killed and
um a living and there was time when I
was a
a slave for the killers and the time was
just to wait till the time they would
kill us when they wanted and yeah it was
the life of miserably it was a miserable
life with no food and every second was a
destiny of death and I know the killers
I know some of the killers were
neighbors and
it's all that we reflect on but we also
reflect on how can we prevent that to
happen again
and it's unimaginable for us to think
about a seven-year-old going through
something like that how do you reflect
on a time like that how do you come to
terms with something so traumatic and so
brutal
yes it takes it takes different things
but uh you know I go back in my village
where my mom still leaves and in that
Village sometimes I wake up and the
person I meet fifth in the morning is
the person who I so are making me a
slave or or wanting to kill me or I saw
killing my my family members and that's
that's that that's what you wake up to
sometimes in the morning and people here
have we we reflect on all that but we
reflect on actually how can we uh
educate to young people how can we tell
the people who would come after us uh
that they will never do that something
like that again and that's what I do and
and that's what um I wake up to do and
that's what um uh the reflection
actually means today for us rwandans who
are here trying to think how can we
build a better future for wandons and
for the world
how do you go about doing that how do
you approach something as big as that as
rebuilding trusts in someone like Rwanda
yeah I mean when you you know that what
um the ideologies the genocide
ideologies that made people uh killing
others in the 1994 genocide against the
Tucci that's what we we we do and and
how do you do that it's finding the
strength finding the the hope that life
is possible looking at where we have
come from 29 years ago and where we are
today it's There's Hope and when you
know that you're working on behalf of
the next Generations that's what make
you wake up do and forgive and and build
trust and I guess without thinking about
the Next Generation the people who come
after us then we cannot do enough
given your memories of you as a
seven-year-old are you surprised at how
far Rwanda has come given what happened
those years ago a relatively recent
history
yes uh but actually what what surprises
me is that people uh is is that people
still have that genocide day duology and
it's you know it's a it's a continuous
it's a continuous work you always work
but uh where we have come from I think I
hope that people have that energy I've
seen the worst of people but I also have
seen the the you know the great uh
kindness of people and I I still have
that hope that people can can do the
great things and so yes it's a surprise
for many but when when we know that
we're working on behalf of us and we're
trying to make the world a better place
and Rwanda better place I think lots of
things have changed but um you know it's
continuous work we still have people who
are who are genocide deniers and we
still have some International
communities who are not still doing
enough to to to stop that transmission
of hatred of ideology and that's what
Pro probably surprises me because when
you have seen something like the
genocide against Tootsie and you still
see people even still denying it 29
years after it's it's what is horrible
than than actually what we can imagine
and I understand that you're an artist
has has that helped you at all come to
terms with the past and look to the
Future do you think in any way
it has because uh when I was you know
after a few months after genocide I
joined the primary school and uh it
hasn't it been the art and the theater I
could not have been you know healed in
the in terms of how I I am because
that's when I told that I started
telling this story through theater and I
still do and you know joining one Young
World also has helped me to continue the
artwork and giving a lot um you know
giving lots of my art
um my art practices to young people who
are in the network of one Young World
and and and it helps me to tell the
story to it helps me to also tell young
people and the world it's it's a channel
it's a very great Channel that I can
only use in in in in the best way
because it it helps to reach and it it
speaks to everyone it's a language that
everyone understands and everyone
listens to and for my own my own way of
healing it has helped me a lot because
when I was sitting in class after after
the genocide I could only feel like I'm
sitting in memories and what I wanted
was only to talk about things I've I've
observed and so it it has been my way of
on my my channel of Healing Art yes it
has and I think I I invite people to
really really really try that and and it
has it's not only myself it has helped a
lot in Rwanda the songs the Arts the
performances all that has helped and it
actually helps a lot in the country when
we are doing uh this 100 days of
commemoration